how are you I'm very fine man yourself
I'm doing well I think you will not you
will not remember but I actually we
spoke 13 years ago Jesus Christ for your
first film in Los Angeles or Toronto one
of those places so you landed on your
feet you were you it's a it's a bad joke
I was I was trying to say I'm glad that
you've had a been able to make many
other films thank you very much
before we get into your new film I just
want to go backwards for a second and
say how much I enjoyed the voices thank
you very much it's me very happy
yeah I thought it was so well done and
you cast Ryan Reynolds before his
popularity with Deadpool yes right yes
because Ryan Reynolds has a capacity of
comedy that you sense when you see him I
mean you know he was very much you know
the actor of the romantic comedy but
when you meet him I mean it's just
sufficient to meet him once and you
understand that you know he has a lot
lot lot in his backpack but you have to
see it and they he was like probably one
of the most delightful people you know
that I ever worked to it you know people
they always ask me like I was right how
is Ryan ran ordinary life is he just as
fun and as nice etc so whatever you see
actually on camera
in reality the guy is 100 times better
so yeah he's the perfect gentleman he is
very funny he's very talented so it was
a great experience to work with him I
loved it yeah I think the people who are
watching this if they have not seen your
film the voices completely different
than this obviously completely
yeah but I'm totally worth watching
thank you very much
jumping in to why I get to talk to you
today talk a little bit about what it
was about this film that says I have to
make this well you know you your agents
my agent talked to me about the script
about Madame Curie and you know I'm a
little bit suspicious because I'm like
why we make a film about Madame Curie
when from the 1940 s it has been so many
film in Syria
the commentary and everything done about
her and everybody knows her then I
received this incredible script written
by Jack Thorne and I started reading the
script and incredible enough the name of
the script is radioactive and it's not
called Marie Curie they live fantastic
destiny for example so I started reading
it and I realized not only is it
extremely well-written script but it is
it goes much beyond a biopic about
Batman and cookie because basically you
talk about what ever happened after her
death like the usage that we have done
from her discoveries and so it becomes a
very challenging script because you know
you have to make flash-forward and you
have to make it in a way that all of
that looks smooth and it has to come at
in the right moment and how to mix all
of that together because the film has a
site that is biopic and that is a site
that is really you know it's almost
surrealistic so you know to combine
these two it becomes very challenging
but then in the film you have all the
elements of whatever I love you have the
romance you have you know like the
questioning of the human being we have
science you have the epic side of the
adverse Tori so all of that made it a
very attractive film for me so I had to
do it it was me and nobody else could do
it
was this one of these projects that was
very difficult to get off the ground or
was it one of these things that once you
got involved the pieces moved pretty
quick but basically my producer said
that you know the script was ready
almost seven years before I was on it
because you know it was a moment that
nobody had any interest in that I think
like they're female movements and me to
change a little bit the thing people
suddenly realized that half of the
population of the world are women so you
know maybe it is normal that half of the
story would be about women and these
women they don't need always to be
attached to someone you know like be
someone's wife and someone's mother and
someone's grandma and someone's lover
you know they can be actually a full
person for themselves
so but I think anytime I have made a
film in my life it has been like that I
have to pretend that the film was going
to happen
if I don't do like if the film is going
to happen it will never happen so you
work basically for more than one year
without knowing if you have the green
light or not you hope that you will have
it and is just by making this effort
that the film is going to happen at the
end and in my mind is always like okay
if they don't greenlight it let's say
they don't greenlight it have I really
lost my time no because I have made all
these researches I have learned so much
so you can never say that you have lost
your time if you have learned something
you have always gained this time
learning something so it's always good
um her life is in her her whole family
everything is so incredible what they
were able to accomplish I would imagine
that even with a great script there are
you know in you're a writer as well that
you there's I'm sure things you wanted
to put in that you couldn't or talked a
little bit about being almost
overwhelmed by how much she did and
trying to do it in the two hours or
you're completely right I mean you know
I mean that's for example her
relationship with Einstein you know with
all the big scientists you know at the
end I have just to put one picture
because if I have to tell this story to
then you know then it's just a whole
film just by itself you know like each
thing of her life can be a whole two
hours frame by itself but then you have
to have a narration and you have to
concentrate and say okay so I have to
have the point of view and I have to
follow this point of view so I have to
tell this story and not another story
because you can make fifteen story let's
say with her story but this is this
story that had I have to say so you have
to you have to choose and it's always
sometimes it's painful because there are
things that deserve to be said that you
like to say so you concentrate it in the
other scene and then yeah you you yeah
it's just lots of concentration and
saying this is what I want to say so
this is what I will say sure I'm always
curious with like scheduling when you're
making a movie you never know what's
gonna be the first day of photography as
a director are you picking out when
you're making a movie what like maybe
what you want to do on the first day to
get people
maybe easing into it or is it sort of
like this is the way the schedule is
let's just go do but I would love to
impose my own schedule saying okay let's
start with that but honestly that never
happens because it's so much dependent
on the economy of the film and what set
is available and the other thing is not
available it's so complicated you know
for the first assistant to make actually
a proper thing when you know it's a
difficult work so I cannot add on that I
try to do the best I can but it's always
the same you know like I always really
like the two first days of the shooting
if I could shoot them again as a two
last days because you know they're never
the best steaks and basically what I
shot the first day was cut out of the
movie so you know this is what happens
at the end but you never have this
possibility this is to say okay let's
make the first day the last day again I
completely understand
yeah I'm always curious about the
editing process because that's the final
rewrite absolutely so I'm curious what
was your reaction when you got in the
editing room with your footage and what
maybe made you very happy and what made
you nervous well the thing is that you
know I work with a great editor who
happens to be my best friend who became
my best friend because and who I work
with him all my film I have the same
editor because it anything as you say is
another rewriting of the story so you
better have someone who understand you
who understand your narration who knows
what you really dislike because you know
what you like can change but these are
things that you hate so it's better that
he's away aware of what you really hate
not to make them and you know it's
always the same procedure you start with
something you're like oh my god I'm a
genius
great what I have done is great and then
a month and a half later you're like I'm
a piece of [ __ ] oh my god it worth
nothing what I did is all [ __ ] you know
it's gonna be a disaster and then you go
back you know from the [ __ ] that okay
let's make a good fair
that actually holds together let's not
be the [ __ ] in that let's not be the
genius like so we're a hit between is
okay try to have a story that holds from
the beginning to the end but you know my
my thing is always a question of rhythm
and my opposition is by the end of the
film because you can make the best film
in the world if the 10 or 15 last
minutes is bad
everybody goes with this idea that you
have made a very bad film no matter what
film it is you have to be able to finish
your film in the right way because if in
the middle you know it's a little bit
like that
that's okay people they forgive it but
you know but you have to start it well
and most importantly have to finish one
your fear in the middle you can be a
little bit smoother with yourself I
think that's why a lot of movies
nowadays are doing things after the
credits to leave you feeling good yeah
exactly but but this is cheating I'm
about to run out of time with you but I
just have to ask as a fan of your work
are you working on anything right now
that people can look forward to after
radioactive well listen in reality is
that you know I'm not a very social
person so you know I like people a lot
especially whether I don't see them very
often so you know like after I have made
of him I really need to be a moment with
myself so now I'm making my paintings to
prepare my second painting exhibition
this is very good for me but also I need
a time to you know swallow new
information to have new impression to
have new feelings because you know once
wasn't making a film I put everything in
this film you know after the film you
know you just bang on me and you is
emptiness is nothing in me I have to
refill myself with many things and then
I would like to say something new and
then that this is the moment to choose
what I want to do you know now is really
two projects that I'm thinking about but
I'm just thinking about them after this
promotion is going to opinion finish I
will be a full-time painter for a couple
of months make money my exhibition and
then if I'm alive still you will see
thank you so much for your time thank
you very Shinzon the movie